another day of protests in
port-au-prince
opposition supporters continued their
calls for the resignation of president
javel noise
[Music]
we cannot accept that juvenile moyes
violates the constitution of the country
we demand that the constitution be
respected
but instead of responding to the
opposition president moyes told
reporters his political rivals had
plotted to overthrow his government
and have him killed
thank you to all my security guards
thank god their plan didn't work
our security personnel will explain in
detail what happened
yesterday the security of the national
palace arrested more than 20
people who had one goal and that was to
leave the country
without me images on social media showed
the arrests of opposition members
including a supreme court judge
a judge was caught in the act there less
than 48 hours ago
he's been captured along with an
inspector general of the police
they were planning to arrest the
president and take him to petit war
at the same time they plan to invade the
palace to install a provisional
president
who already had his speech prepared in
this case
we cannot speak of immunity
the arrests come on the day that
opposition leaders say the president's
mandate in office was supposed to end
well everything i'm hearing from haiti
and just gathering the strands is that
um this is actually a an attack against
the opposition party as kind of an
excuse
uh to round up opponents the people who
have been arrested are a number of
prominent voices who have been
critiquing his regime
um so to me it seems like the story is a
cover for
something very different tensions in
haiti remain high
as opposition leaders have vowed to
continue to put pressure on the maui's
government
and have called for more demonstrations
manuel rapalo
al jazeera